It's time
to play Poster Children.
Poster Children.
If you can remember the '70s,
you weren't there, man.
Or you were probably
not even born.
Uh, I-I wasn't.
I was born in, like, '80...
(stammers)
...eight.
Um, either way, that decade
was jammed
with primitive inspirational
posters that adorned the walls
of junior high guidance offices.
We found an archive of these
wonderful, inspirational
roll-ups on westword.com.
So comedians, some
of the messages on the posters
seem like unfinished thoughts.
So for 250 points, just tell us
the rest of the phrase.
First up,
"Know and accept yourself."
Matt.
Your mom was a horse
and your dad was a cowboy
and that makes you
a beautiful centaur.
-You can't see. -Oh, yeah, you
can't see from the waste down.
You can't see
from the waist down.
Yeah, it's all...
it's all horse down here.
-Just all horse.
-See?
Yeah. Hari.
Uh, you will never
get off this farm.
Grace.
What happened between and you
Farmer Bill is in the past.
Yeah. Points.
All right, next,
"Tell it truthfully."
Uh, Hari.
Your dick is a fish.
Mm-hmm. Yup. Yup.
-Yeah.
-KONDABOLU: Obviously.
Points.
Grace.
You drowned that blind kid,
didn't you?
Next one.
"I'm okay and you're okay."
Grace.
It's normal for three
out of four teens
to (bleep) their pants
playing basketball.
Points.
Wait a minute.
To be fair...
To be fair, this one looks like
he's really trying not to.
"I'm not gonna be the fourth."
And she is freaking
the (bleep) out about it.
Yeah, she's like... -What's
going on?
You-you know why--
he's... he wiped some
on the ball. Look.
Like, dude, stop.
I don't want to play four square
anymore with you.
Next, "Things we learn
can help us now."
"Things we learn can..." Hey,
look, they're reading a magazine
called Fun. Look at how much fun
they're having, Hari.
Perhaps there is
information in here
that will get us out of this
stranger's basement.
Braunger.
Dock worker Jim says this
magazine Fun is the filthiest
porno mag you can
get your hands on.
I mean, it's practically
illegal, dude.
Yeah, points.
Points.
-Oh.
-Next one.
"Every member
of a group is important."
"Every member of a group
is important." Matt Braunger.
Even Rusty, who's too stoned
to get off the bench.
Yeah, points.
Yup.
-Hey, man.
-What?
Hari.
How come only the white kids
get to play?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh... Oh, you know why?
Uh, this is the, uh, Oscar's
league, uh, softball team.
Oh!
Get 'em.